hey y'all if y'all need any magazines
talk to little amir and dalia okay them
girls need to be supported they're
trying to go to honduras to build canoes
in the fall okay it's hot
is twine still doing hvac
no no no no jesus you're right you're
right but i don't got enough tomatoes on
me to throw at him jesus little guard
you didn't give me none
all right well since i can't shoot the
messenger
i replace him all right y'all before we
get to the word
we gonna
we gonna invite up the lovely nori
noreen's daughter
noreen's daughter y'all yes nina's gonna
come up here and tell us about the
situation that her mama's going through
i'm not doing that
she got a beard in her pantyhose thing
do you want me to say that in the
microphone come on baby you're our only
hope okay
you just gotta think of something nice
to say like
she didn't smoke while she was pregnant
with you
she did though
look at my little hands damn right
all right
i'll do it thank you all right
as you can imagine nina is under quite a
bit of emotional distress
so i'm going to be speaking on her
behalf okay it looks like uh we got
nina's roommate coming up here to share
with us okay come on
uh what can i say about
miss noreen
she's uh
many things
so many things lord a whole lot of
things a lot of things she's uh she's
she's present
very uh very present wherever i like
wherever i'm walking she's she's right
there so many sets of footprints lord
mm-hmm mm-hmm
there are times when when she's not
present
uh but i know that's the devil tricking
me because
she shows up again
be gone satan stop that
some nights i i lay awake craving
yearning
howling
for noreen to have her house again
i am hurting for it lord i am bursting
with desire for noreen to have a home or
somewhere else to sleep
i wake up wet lord
with with with tears and stuff
wipe me down king jesus god please
uh
what what what don't what i'm saying is
give big so i could get some peace
hmm
uh she uh
uh
she worse than me huh
i have a testimony
big suit bastard excuse me
ha ha
oh god wanted me to tell y'all how i
became a quadruple threat and i'm gonna
fulfill his wishes through acting
to be or not to be
dance oh
what disciples
dance praise hallelujah
united my guy
and of course
you go ahead and move hill sweaty man
do the remedy why does deuteronomy have
nothing to do with doo doo huh
you